There is nothing worse
than having a song stuck
in your head that don't get out.
Cue the rage in three, two--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hey everyone, Laci
Green here for D News.
I'm very ashamed to admit
it, but every time I
hear that song "Timber"
on the radio it just goes
around and around and around
in my head like a broken record
player.
This is, of course,
not the first time
a dumb song has been
stuck in my head
and it probably
won't be the last.
I've been asking myself,
"What the hey, brain?
What is going on up there?"
Here's what scientists have to
say about "earworms," or songs
that get stuck in your
head-- uh, well, they're
not entirely sure.
That's the great
thing about science,
you can always count on it to
admit what it doesn't know.
Here's what we do know-- it
happens when you least expect
it or when you're zoning out,
doing chores, driving-- which
you shouldn't be zoning out
during, but hey, it happens--
or taking a shower.
We also know that it
happens with songs
we've heard a bunch of times,
which explains why earworms are
often songs that are played
endlessly on the radio.
We also know that
earworms are more
common with repetitive, upbeat
songs, especially those that
have some kind of
unexpected element
to a track that makes
it only slightly
different from other
similar melodies.
Using MRI scans,
Dartmouth researchers
found that participants had
activated auditory cortices
while they listened to a
familiar clip of music.
And then after the
clip ended, the cortex
remained lit up, the brain
essentially continuing
to fill in the gaps
and sing on its own.
This was especially
true in individuals
with high levels of neuroticism.
The researchers believe
that a song's melody may by
summoned not only by repetition
but by something subconsciously
related to it or perhaps
hearing another song that
has a similar few notes.
Pair this with high levels
of neuroticism and your brain
is much more likely
to catch the earworm.
Another theory
posed by researchers
at the University
of Cincinnati is
that earworms are
a way for the mind
to occupy itself while
it's idling, hence
being more prone while
you're zoning out.
And while most people
describe earworms
as a neutral or positive
experience, having
one that just won't get
out of your freaking head
can be really annoying.
I find that it's not
very positive for me,
but maybe that's just
because it's usually songs
that I don't like.
If you're like me, try
listening to another song
or occupying
yourself in some way.
Just don't think about the song,
which I realize kind of makes
you want to think about it more.
So you really gotta
commit yourself
to fully engaged distraction.
Another technique is
listening to the song
all the way through.
Apparently, just giving
that itch a good scratching
is all it takes for some people.
So folks, what song
gets stuck in your head?
Let me know down below and
may the massive triggering
of earworms begin.
Thanks for joining
me, we'll be back soon
with more science updates.